that's what i'm talking about baby
that's that's that's growth
as a player guys in that video clip
well these two have gone out at giannis
and blake griffin injuries seem to
dictate the detroit lineup night tonight
blake griffin can go tonight
he's in the front court with jeremy
grant mason plumley wayne ellington
and delon wright are the guards killian
hayes who has been starting
is out after being injured here on
monday night the mega bucks line up
chris middleton giannis out of the kubo
group lopez dante
vincenzo and drew holiday
the fox have used the same starting five
for all eight games milwaukee has won 29
of its last 31 games within the central
division
including eight straight over detroit
the officials tonight two of them are
the same as monday
matt bowling the referee umpire nate
green worked here
two days ago the crew chief is new
courtney kirkland in his
21st nba season
so with lake griffin matched up against
ghana to get
a veteran defender been in the league a
long time the pistons hope that uh
well off the opening tip
the teams both take a knee
in their continuing tribute to social
justice
the coaching staff of the milwaukee
bucks also taking a knee
[Applause]
and like the fact that it was both teams
you may not agree or disagree but both
teams
showing some solidarity solidarity here
early and now it's time to play
basketball
the bucks winning the opening tip
and now of course detroit will inbound
side court delon wright for blake
griffin
and they will go down on a knee again
and milwaukee will get possession
[Applause]